lorsque 12e et l'oscar est décerné à
jessica chastain
[Applaudissements]
ces deux premières gardes et la
troisième nomination pour jessica
chastain
[Applaudissements]
là
et qu'il rende merci merci
bien sûr merci merci du fond du coeur à
l'académie de cette récompense
sans aucun doute je ne serai pas sur
cette scène je n'aurais maintenant à
deux derrière sans fil des coups et les
menaces
ni copenhague
je vous aime du fond du coeur et merci
pour tout ce que vous avez fait je dois
le dire je dois dire oniris ten nicole
pénélope olivia je vous ai eu tellement
j'ai tant d'admiration pour vous et à
partager une catégorie avec vous c'est
un honneur incommensurable permettez moi
d'adresser mes remerciements des cochons
c'est le réalisateur qu'il y a c'est un
espace qui a inspiré la créativité
l'amour le club méridien à l'est qui est
incroyable de la coiffure maquillage qui
vraiment m'a permis de trouver mon
personnage les producteurs kelly michael
ritchie merci également à bing aux
sunlights qui s'est occupé de ce film
[Applaudissements]
mes partenaires de la scène en devenant
partenaire andrew garfield qui est juste
brillant et qu'ils sont match merci du
fond du coeur d'avoir fait sortir le
meilleur de moi même en te présentant
tous les jours avec le meilleur de toi
[Musique]
sortons d'une période particulièrement
difficile qui a causé beaucoup de
traumatismes et d'isolement et nous
savons qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui se
trouvent désarçonné qui ont le sentiment
d'être seul
une des grandes causes de décès aux
états unis sa touche et de l'indre
famille y compris ma famille et
notamment des membres de la communauté
lgbt cul qui ont l'impression de ne pas
être à leur place même aux côtés de leur
père
nous sommes confrontés à brec'h de
discrimination il ya une législation
tordu
véritablement
fait que nous sommes de plus en plus
divisés il y a beaucoup de violences des
crimes de perpétrer contre des civils
innocents et partout dans le monde et je
crois que dans de telles périodes nous
pouvons penser à samy et la pensée être
inspiré par son amour radical sa manière
va du kgb nous avons beaucoup parlé
d'amour je suis inspirée par sa
compassion c'est un principe directeur
qui doit nous porter de l'avonex à 100
et je crois que ces principes nous
connecte dans cette volonté celle d'être
acceptée pour ce que nous sommes être
acceptée pour qu'ils nous iman et
d'avoir aussi la possibilité de vivre
une vie sans craindre d'être victimes de
violence ou de terrorisme
coup dur et pour toutes celles et ceux
qu'ils
vous sentez sans espoir vous sentez seul
sachez que vous êtes né mais de manière
inconditionnelle pour l'unicité de votre
être
oui au taureau du riatt à montrésor
joliette un opus tu sors mes 13 ans vous
êtes mon coeur et je vous remercie une
nouvelle fois du fond du coeur
[Musique]